BRADY HARAN: Hi there,
everyone.
Today I want to talk to you
about perfect numbers.
No, not those perfect numbers.
We've done them already.
I want to talk to you about
the perfect numbers
of sports and games.
Now, probably the sport most
associated with the term
perfect game is baseball.
That's because a baseball
pitcher can
throw a perfect game.
Barring unusual circumstances,
that's 27 up, 27 down.
Retiring every batter without
any of them making it to base.
Seeing we're kind of talking
about strikes, 12 in a row is
the goal for 10 pin bowlers.
That's a score of 300
across 10 frames.
There are two extra balls
to satisfy the
quirky scoring system.
Now, my preferred sport
is cricket.
Now, a cricket bowler can bowl
a hat trick, but that's not
really, really special.
Cricket in perfection, in my
opinion, is for the batsman.
And the accomplishment
thereafter is
six 6's in an over.
It's only happened twice in
first class cricket, and twice
at international level.
In darts, it's a
9 dart finish.
501 points from just 9 throws.
Apparently, there are 3,944
different ways to accomplish
it, the majority requiring a
bullseye with the final throw,
although that's not always the
most common way to do it.
On the snooker table, a perfect
break is the much
sought after 147.
All 15 reds with a black,
then the 6 colors.
But although it is called a
maximum, higher breaks are
technically possible.
Athletics used to have the four
minute mile, but that's
long gone since Roger Bannister
broke that one.
What is it at the moment?
Probably the best one is
the 2 hour marathon.
Who's going to be the first
person to run that race in
less than 120 minutes?
Tennis has a golden set.
Six games in a row without
conceding a point.
That is 24 points in a row.
It's extremely rare, though
it did happen at
Wimbledon this year.
Golfing perfection, well, that's
as simple as it gets.
A hole in one.
Many professionals wait a
lifetime to hit one, although
former North Korean leader Kim
Jong Il once hit five in a
single round.
Well, allegedly.
It's not all about sport.
There are other games where
you can achieve numbery
perfection, and anyone who's
been watching my videos lately
will know I've become a little
bit obsessed with dice.
In the game of Yahtzee, if
you're using the bonus point
system, the miracle score
would be 1,575.
And I'm pretty sure that's never
happened, unless Kim
Jong Il played Yahtzee once.
The odds of being directly dealt
poker's ultimate hand, a
royal flush, is 649,713 to 1.
So how amazing was that?
The highest opening
move in a game of
Scrabble is this 128 pointer.
Or using another dictionary,
this 130 pointer.
The highest possible move in
general play, well, that's a
vexed question, and
it depends on what
dictionary you're using.
But if this hypothetical board
ever presented itself, you
could play this move
for 2044 points.
And I bet even Kim
Jong Il would be
impressed by that one.
So we'll leave it there for now,
but I know there's a lot
more games and sports
where we could talk
about perfect numbers.
Perhaps leave some ideas
underneath the video, we'll
make another video soon.
And finally, a short apology to
all those Red Sox fans out
there.
--Somehow continue to
find it amazing.
I haven't done 105
of these yet.
You can see some cool patterns
coming and going on the top.
People watching the video can
count along to make sure I've
done all 105.